four months ago Mahaveer hora Juan's
mother was murdered in this house
villagers here were convinced she was a
witch
so they beheaded her or won a migrant
worker was away helping support the
family he couldn't stop the killing he
had at home as soon as he heard the news
told me they had killed my mother in
this house then I came here and saw all
the blood I had to clean it myself
he still can't believe what happened
police say they haven't caught the
suspects and are still investigating
Mahavira says his mother had long been
accused of being a witch a rumor his
family tried their best to guellen
villagers always said that my mother was
a witch so what did you do we went to a
healer to prove that she wasn't we
wanted to show everyone here in the poor
eastern state of Jharkhand women accused
of being witches come to heaters like
[ __ ] a turkey he says he has the power
to heal witches and rid them of their
magic a well-known figure in these parts
he says he recognizes witches a woman
who was affected by black magic she
became cruel and mentally ill she didn't
want to comb her hair she didn't take
baths or eat anything she talked very
little this stick he says helps heal
them he claims to have already saved the
lives of 10 women with it the stick was
provided by Lord Hanuman accusations of
witchcraft are familiar calls of
violence towards women here witch hunts
are especially frequent among the
adivasi an indigenous group when people
fall ill or die women are sometimes
suspected of witchery and brutally
murdered Rahul Mehta works for a local
aid organization working to stop the
killer
Rahul says some 300 to 400 women are
killed every year but about 80% of cases
are not reported many people say the
women did not die because they were
witches but for other reasons the
killings are often a taboo topic here
near the city of Ranchi no one we came
across would talk to us about witches
finally we found one woman who would she
tells us her sister was accused of being
a witch and was chased out of the
village here in the safety of her home
other women also began to open up Janki
devi says she's often called a witch
behind her back I feel scared in the
village because I hear that women are
killed here and there the 40 year old
says she knows why many believe she
dabbles in the dark arts nobody here is
educated as my children that is why the
villagers are jealous they wonder how we
achieved all we have jealousy are
disputes about land ownership are often
the real reason for witch hunts
superstition is often used as a cover
for criminal activity a practice
consigned to history in many countries
but in India it remains a terrifying
reality for many women